Speaker 1: Let's hear from the people in the
audience. These are the most important people.
We missed live calls last week because of my
absence. A very timely absence, I would say.
We do live calls via discord. You can join the
discord at David Pacman dot com slash discord.
And we are going to start today with George
from Virginia. George from Virginia. Welcome
to the program. What's on your mind today, sir?
Speaker 2: Hey, David, can you hear me? Yes,
I can. Oh, excellent. Excellent.
So I wanted to bring up something with RFK
that I think a lot of people are kind of
glossing over to focus on the vaccine stuff.
Speaker 1: Okay. You're talking about Bobby
kennedy Jr. Democratic presidential candidate.
Speaker 2: Yes, that is correct. Good. So he
I don't know if you saw he was
had two interviews on breaking
points. No, I didn't see that in principal.
Speaker 1: I didn't see that.
Speaker 2: Oh, okay. Well, I would I would
recommend you go check him out because he reveals
a lot of information about what he wants to do
in certain areas. Okay. And in the first one,
he said something that was really troubling. He
he said that when it comes to climate change,
he believes that the solution is having
a truly free energy market. Right. And.
When I hear that, I get very nervous because
I think of Texas. Right. And and Texas has I
don't know if you know your viewers know this, but
Texas has a deregulated energy market where it's
supposed to drive down costs and lower pollution.
But I look this up. Texas is actually one of the
top ten most polluted states in the country.
Speaker 1: And not only that, they've had
these issues where because their electrical
system is not connected to the greater grid,
when they had the winter storms, when they
had the summer heat waves and power outages,
they were they were basically screwed, for lack of
a better term because they didn't have neighboring
resources they could pull from. It's been a
disaster in Texas. Now, listen, I'm aware of what
you're saying with Bobby Kennedy Jr. And I know
that he favors a very sort of like pro-corporate
in a sense situation when it comes to energy. And
I just don't believe that there's evidence that
that actually will work. There are all sorts of
different reasons that we could look at, including
the fact that really to get us out of the status
quo in a way where we will move in the direction
of truly renewable energy. There is this interim
period during which we actually almost certainly,
I believe, certainly will need government
involvement through both regulation and subsidies.
We're going to need regulation and subsidies
in order to start making some really important
transitions. I believe that if it's left to the
free market, sure, they might happen decades later
than they otherwise would, and in a way that
will be dramatically damaging to the planet.
So I just hope and it sounds like you agree with
me on this, George, I disagree with Bobby Kennedy
Jr. That that's the way to fix climate change.
Speaker 2: Yeah. And I think a lot of people
misunderstand the fact that he, as a lawyer
can fight for for justice when it comes to
environmental things. But his solution as
a policy maker can be bad at the same time.
Speaker 1: Absolutely. Yeah.
So very eloquently said George.
Speaker 2: Thank you. So, yeah, that was
all I had. And I appreciate it, David.
Speaker 1: All right, George from
Virginia making some excellent points.